foreign
keeping everyone safe out here and keep
an eye on what's going on so um just a
big thank you for what you do on a
day-to-day basis and I know some of you
coming to the end of your your time out
here so looking forward to a bit of our
alarm to get home uh but you're doing a
really important job out here and
defending our freedoms is really
important and everyone back home
Authority supports you and everything
you're doing with the the polls and our
polish counterparts in providing that
safety is really important so thank you
for your time love to meet you all and
um Good Luck thank you
happy
[Music]
birthday
you've been here
[Music]
how long have you been here
for one year for the whole year
well the 12th of April it will be one
year since she has been in the house
here